[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض نرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
باستعاده القرم ووسطن تدرس تزويد اوكرانيا
باسلحه لضرب اهداف روسيه هناك
[تصفيق]
اطلاق سراح ماهر يونس بعد 40 عاما في سجون
اسرائيل والشابات يهدد المحتفلين بهدم
بيته
اضرابات عماليه مليونيه اليوم قد تشل حياه
الفرنسيين والمخابرات تتخوفوا من اتساع
رقعتها
واغفر لنا اوروبا يصوت اليوم على خطه لوضع
الحرس الثوري الايراني على قائمه الارهاب
وطهران تحذر
حياكم الله البدايه من تطورات الحرب
الاوكرانيه حيث تعاهد الرئيس الاوكراني
فولدي ميرسي باستعادته شبه جزيره القرم من
روسيا داعيا الغرب الى تزويد بلاده بمزيد
من الاسلحه من جهه اخرى قال ذلك ان هناك
فرضيات متعدده وراء سقوط مروحيه وزير
الداخليه
يتم التحقيق فيها وتشير تصريحاتك الى ان
التحقيقات وضعت احتمالات لتعرض مروحيات
وزير الداخليه لهجوم وانها لا تقتصر على
العطل الفني هذا ونشرت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز تقارير تفيد بان الرئيس الامريكي
لاوكرانيا بقصفه جزيره القرم كما ذكرت ان
اداره بيض تقدم اسلحه لاوكرانيا قادره على
ضرب اهداف حيويه روسيه في القرن مشيره الى
ان الاداره الامريكيه تعتقدوا ان استهداف
القرن سيسهل الضغط على روسيا لتفاوض
وكشف مسؤول كبير في البنتاغون انه واشنطن
تعملوا على منحي اوكرانيا القدرات
العسكريه اللازمه لتغيير وجهه الحرب من
مدرعات ودفاعات جويه لكنها لم تقدم دبابات
ابرامز ذات التكنولوجيا المتقدمه المسؤول
الامريكي في البنتاجون وصف الحرب في منطقه
باخمود وسوليدار بالشبيهه بالحرب العالميه
الاولى لشده عنفها
وانتقد الرئيس الاوكراني
بتردد المانيا في تزويد بلاده بدبابات
وكان مسؤولون المان كبار قالوا ان المانيا
لن تسمح للحلفاء بجميع او شحني دبابات
المانيه الصنع الى اوكرانيا للمساعده في
دفعها ضد روسيا ولن ترسل الانضمتها الخاصه
ما لم توافق الولايات المتحده على ارسال
الدبابات قتاليه امريكيه الصنعه
ينضم الينا منكير مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل اهلا بك معنا حنيفه اذا تصريحات
زنسكي وامتعاضه من المانيا لعدم ارسال هذه
الدبابات ما لم ترسل الولايات المتحده
دبابات ما شان ذلك وكيف هو ردود الفعل
الداخليه حول الموقف الالماني
هل تسمعني حذيفه
طيب
سنعود اليك بعد قليل اذا في تطور لافت
مشاهدينا طالب اعضاء بالكونجرس الامريكي
بمراقبه المساعدات الامريكيه لاوكرانيا
حيث اصدر النائب الجمهوري مايكل رئيس لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس النواب والنائب
الامريكي مايكروجرز رئيس لجنه القوات
المسلحه بمجلس النواب اصدر بيانا لدعم
زياده الرقابه على المساعدات الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا وطلب ايضا بالضمان انفاق
المساعدات الامريكيه بشفافيه وفعاليه
وتعزيز وصالح الامن القومي للولايات
المتحده
من المقرر ان يصوت اعضاء البرلمان
الاوروبي اليوم على خطه للمطالبه بادراج
الحرس الثوري الايراني والمرشد علي خامني
والرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي على قوائم العقوبات
وتشهد الدول الاوروبيه بما في ذلك
بريطانيا تشهد نقاشا داخليا حول وضع الحرس
على القائمه السوداء ففيما سيناقشه وزراء
خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي التقرير في
السابع والعشرين من الشهر الحالي لكن
تصويت المشرعين غير ملزم للاجتماع
وكان قد اكد المتحدث باسمي وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه نت بريس اكد تعاون واشنطن مع
اوروبا ضد تحديدات الحرس الثوري الايراني
برايس قال ان الحرس الثوري اظهر رغبه
بغيضه في ازهاق ارواح الابرياء مؤكدا ان
لا وجود لمصدر ارهاب اكثر شراسه من النظام
الايراني على الساحه الدوليه بحسب وصفه في
المقابل حذر وزير الخارجيه ايران حسين
امير عبد الله الاتحاد الاوروبي من تصنيف
الحارس الثوري على قوائم الارهاب وقال عبد
الالهيان ان الاتحاد الاوروبي وبهذه
الخطوه سيطلق النار على قدميه ويكون لذلك
تداعيات وعواقبه وخيمه لانه يتعارض مع
العقلانيه السياسيه والمدنيه على حديقه
جاء هذا بعد ان دعم البرلمان الاوروبي
الاتحاد الاوروبي الى ادراج الحرس الثوري
منظمه ارهابيه واتهامه بقمع المتظاهرين في
البلاد وامداد روسيا بطائرات مسيره وكما
حذر نائب البرلمان الايراني اسماعيل كوثري
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي من عوا ستواجهها
حالا مضيف في تصنيف الحرس الثوري ضمن
قائمه الارهاب كوثري الجنرال البارز في
الحرس الثوري وعضو لجنه الامن القومي قال
ان القرار الاوروبي المقترح لتصنيف الحرس
الثوري ضمن الارهاب لن يقيد شيئا بل سيغير
الاوضاع لاخرى مشيرا الى ان تلك الاجراءات
تغلق ابواب التفاوض مع ايران
من بروكسل ينضم الينا عفوا سنعود لذلك
لاحقا الولايات المتحده الملكيه طلبت ودول
الاوروبيه ايضا طلبوا ايران بالافراج
الفوري عن رعاياهم القابعين في سجون
الظهران وذلك بسبب حاجتهم الى رعايه صحيه
ومتابعه طبيه لا تتوفر في مكان احتياجهم
وصفه مطالبات بوضع حد لنهجي قائم على حجز
رهائن اجانب كوارقه لمساومه الغرب
اعتقال الرعايه الاجانب في ايران يثير
مخاوف الولايات المتحده وبلدان اوروبيه من
مصير مجهول يخيم على مواطنها القابعين في
سجون طهران ففي الايام الاخيره فقط برزت
اربع قضايا اليراها اين يعانون من ظروف
احتجاز قاسيه وحتى اسباب اعتقالهم مشكوك
فيها
الامريكي الايراني سيا ماكناماسي المعتقل
منذ اكثر من سبع سنوات
رهينه الفرنسي الايرلندي
بعد ما تم اعتقاله في اكتوبر الماضي
بدريعه التجسس وتقول الخارجيه الفرنسيه
انه بحاجه لمتابعه طبيه لا تتوافر في مكان
احتجاجه البلجيكي اوليفي فاليكاستل تم
اعتقاله ايران قبل عام وتصف الحكومه
البلجيكيه هذا الاعتقال بانه كان تعسفيا
ومن دون ادله حقيقيه على ما تروج له طهران
بان الرجل يعمل لصالح استخبارات اجنبيه
بينما يعيش حاليا في ظروف غير انسانيه
اما اخر ضحايا الاعتقالات الايرانيه ضد
الرعايه الاجانب فهو الماني بذريعه تصويره
منشات نفطيه في مدينه ايميدي دون الاعلان
عن تفاصيل اخرى او معرفه اسمه النظام
الايراني وحسب سلطات القضائيه
اجانب حيث تم تسجيل واحتقال مالا يقل عن
اربعين اجنبيه خلال الاحتجاجات المندلعه
منذ سبتمبر الماضي فيما يبرر النظام
الاعتقالات بانها تاتي بسبب المساسب الامن
القومي للبلاد وان الاعتقالات تمت بموجب
القانون وظهران مستعده لتبا سجن مع الغرب
ومع استمرار ايران في عمليه الاعتقالات
وحملات القمع وانتهاك حقوق الانسان تواعدت
الولايات المتحده ودول اوروبيه بالرده
ووضع حد لنهج قائم على حجرهانا اجانب
كوارقه لمساومه الغرب
القومي الى البيت الابيض
لاجراء محادثات مع مسؤولين اسرائيليين
وذلك حول تطورات الملف النووي الايراني
وتعقيدات حكومه نتنياهو وفي تصريحات
للعربيه اوضحت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
انا واشنطن تسعه لتهدئه التوترات بين
اسرائيل وفلسطين من دون تصعيد اي منهما
كما تهدف الى حل دولتين الا ان تحقيق ذلك
لن يكون قريبا
مستمرين معكم مشاهدينا في تغطيه التطورات
الاوكرانيه وحول ذلك ينضم الينا من كيف
مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل اهلا بكم معنا
حذيفه اذا انقل لنا اخر التطورات لديك على
الميدان
بحادثه التي حدثت بالامس طبعا انتهت
عمليات البحث والانقاذ والحصيله الاخيره
هي 14 قتيلا بينهم طفل واحد وهنالك 29
جريحا طبعا
بوزير الداخليه واعضاء من وزاره الداخليه
وادت الى وفاتهم صحيح
هذا صحيح طبعا والان يعني قبل قليل كان
هنالك بيان عن اخر يعني اخر رقم للضحايا
وحول هذه الحادثه وهذا البيان تحدث عن هذه
الارقام 14 قتيلا بينهم جريح بينهم طفل 29
جريحا هنالك كبيره الاطباء ايضا تحدث عن
خمسه من الجرحى في حاله حرجه ثلاثه اطفال
في حاله حرجه وشخصان بالغين همم في همم
المستشفى طبعا هذه الحادثه مباشره بعدها
قامت همم قام الرئيس السابنسكي ومجلس
الوزراء بتعيين مدير الشرطه الوطنيه نائب
لوزير الداخليه وموكل اليه مهام همم وزير
الداخليه حتى يقوم همم مجلس الوزراء
والبرلمان بالتشاور لتعيين وزير جديد اما
على صعيد جبهات القتال طبعا الجبهه
الاساسيه هي جبهه باخبط هناك القتال
يشتدوا مستمر كان هنالك تنفيذ حوالي تسعه
ضربات جويه من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه في
مناطق تمركز القوات الروسيه والمعدات ايضا
الذخائر وكما نفذ ايضا ال- نفذ الروس ايضا
اكثر من 15 ضربه جويه وعدد من الضربات
الصاروخيه في مناطق مختلفه همم الشيء
الاساسي هو القصف براجمات الصواريخ في خط
الدفاع في خط الهجوم الاول في اتجاه باخبط
وكذلك في لمان في اتجاه لمان وفي اتجاه
كوبنس كما زالت القوات الروسيه تحاول ان
تحشد الموارد يعني
الاوروبيين يحاولون ارسال المزيد من
المساعدات لاوكرانيا فما لديك حول ذلك
وتحديدا الانعاض الاوكراني حول الرفض
الالماني لارسال الدبابات لاوكرانيا
طبعا بخصوص هذه الدبابات يعني كان هنالك
تفاؤل كبير وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني بعد
ان زارت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
اوكرانيا وتحديدا خط القتال او خط الجبهه
او قريب من خط الجبهه في مدينه في خاركه
همم يعني خرج وصرح وقال انه يتوقع قريبا
ان تكون الدبابات الالمانيه في الخطوط
القتال الاماميه وطبعا لذلك امتوحات كبير
من مثل هذا القرار طبعا تعلمين ان القاده
الاوروبيون الاوروبيين ما زال يتعاملون
بحذر كبير حولت عمليه التصعيد في هذه
الحرب خاصه طبعا بعد التصريحات الاخيره
للاتحاد
الروسي وكان على مستوى القاده السياسيين
او العسكريه طبعا تعلمين انه هنالك
مساعدات جديده امريكيه بثلاثه فاصل سبعه
مليار
شكرا لك همم
كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
اطلقت مصلحه السجون الاسرائيليه سراح
الاسير الفلسطيني ماهر يونس فيما منعت
الشرطه الاسرائيليه اي مظاهر احتفاليه
باطلاق سراحها على الرغم من معاقبته
بالسجن 40 عاما متواصله وهددت بتفريق اي
تجمع جماهيري لاستقباله في قريته عاره
داخل اسرائيل وهددت بهدمه بيته
مراسله العربيه تنضم الينا وتحديدا من
منزل الاسير ماهر يونس في قريه عاره اهلا
بك معنا لنا جديد لديك حول اطلاق سراحه
وكيف هو وضعها الان
نحن الان متواجدون امام منزل عائله الاسير
المحرر ماهر يونس وقد اقضي محبوبيته وهي
40 عاما في السجون الاسرائيليه واليوم هو
يعانق الحريه يعني معنى الان ايضا اخ الاس
وهو نادر ال ال نادر يونس هل لك ان تخبرنا
عن كيف هو وضع ايضا الاسير ونحن نعلم بان
ايضا القوات الاسرائيليه قامت بي يعني
منعه ايضا من توديع اصدقائه ايضا
المناضلين في السجون الاسرائيليه هل لك ان
تخبرنا بباقي التفاصيل
كل عربي شريف في هذا الوطن على التحرير
قصه انه منعو من توزيع اهله كان هناك في
التباس انه اطلع مع غضك او ما تطلعش مع
غلطك فكان هناك في اقتباس في الموضوع
وبالاخر ودع اصحابه
بالطريقه الخاصه وكان له احتفال في السجن
قبل لا طلع والحمد لله رب العالمين اهم
شيء انه هو يعني يتنشق هواء الحريه واليوم
احنا موجودين بين اهل موجود بين اهله وبين
قايبه وعائله حاضنه له والحمد لله رب
العالمين
الفلسطيني ومنع التجمهر دعنا نقول ويعني
لذلك نحن نشهد ايضا يعني بالرغم من هذه
التهديدات هناك مئات او دعنا نقول عشرات
الفلسطينيين توجهوا الى هنا وهم يستقبلونا
الاسير
اول شيء اهلا وسهلا بالنسبه للاستزازات
اللي صارت مع الشرطه همم طبعا احنا متوقع
طبعا همم علم او عدم رفع العلم ااه يعني
الاسير هو علم بنفسه هو علم بذاته فهو مش
ناقصه عدم احنا يعني نحاول يعني الاجتياز
هيك المرحله كلياتها بدون اي اشتباك مع
الشرطه او غير شرطه همم احنا ما بنسمحش
لاي انسان ونفسد علينا فرحتنا نحن نستقبل
الناس بكل
هناك طبعا الغذاء وكل شيء فجر سيتم بواجب
الناس واهلا وسهلا بالجميع فيعني قصه
الشرطه نحن نرى ان يعني هاي حكومه بن جرير
يعني مش واضح يعني ان شو اللي قبل
بيتصرفوا هاي هذا موجود اما ان شاء الله
بعاملين هاي محنه
بكره ان شاء الله بالسلامه
الفلسطينيه وربما يعني هنا الفلسطينيين قد
يعني قد صغولي امره ولم يرفع حتى الان
الاعلام الفلسطينيه
على الداخل الفلسطيني وهو حتى الاسرى
الفلسطينيين الذين قالوا اكثر من اربع
يعني 40 عاما في السجون الاسرائيليه حتى
الاحتفال يمنع برفع العلم الفلسطيني هذه
هي الاجواء عشرات من الفلسطينيين يتوافدون
الان الى هذه الساحه حيث توجد عائله
الاسير همم ايضا متواجدون هنا فهذه هي
الصوره حتى الان شكرا لك مراسله العربيه
الى هناك العاصي من منزل الاسير ماهر يونس
في قريه تعارف
خلاص خلاص
اخر قتل فلسطينيان برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي
خلال اقتحامه مخيم جنين شمالا الضفه
الغربيه وبحسب مراسل العربيه قتل الجيش
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني في مخيم جنين
للاجئين الفلسطينيين اثناء محاوله اعتقال
غير ناجحه لاحد القاده الميدانيين لحركه
الجهاد مع وقوع عدد من المصابين ايضا واكد
المتحدث باسمي وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان الولايات المتحده تسعى للمساعده في
تهدئه التوترات وتشجيع الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين على الامتناع عن التصعيد
مضيفا ان حل الدولتين هو هدفه واشنطن لكن
تحقيقه لن يكون قريبا
لكن نايس دافي بويكندراني
لذا فان المهمه الاولى كما نراها هي ان
نفعل ما في وسعنا للمساعده في تهدئه
التوترات ولتشجيع الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين على الامتناع عن التصعيد لا
يزال نهجون على المدى الطويل يتمثل في دعم
حل الدولتين ونامل في نهايه المطاف ان
يعيش الاسرائيليون والفلسطينيين جنبا الى
جنب ويتمتعون بمقاييس متساويه من
الاستقرار نحن ندرك ان حل الدوله تين بعيد
لا احد يتحدث في الوقت الحالي عن امكانيه
اجراء حوار بناء على المدى القريب متوج
بحل الدولتين بين الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين
في الداخل الاسرائيلي يسعى رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو لاحتواء
تداعيات قرار المحكمه العليا برفض توزير
او توزيع رئيس حزب شخصي درعي في الحكومه
بسبب ادانته السابقه بقضيه فساد الماليه
الاسرائيليه التي قررت باغلبيه 10 قضاه في
مقابل معارضه واحد الغاء تعيين رئيس حزب
سياسه في الحكومه بسبب ادانته في قضيه
فساد ما يعني انعل نتنياهو ان يقيله من
منصبه وما يعني ايضا بان الحرب على النظام
القضائي التي تسميها الحكومه اصلاحات
ستستعر ازواج دستوريه وربما
ازمايتلافيه ولكن مما لا شك فيه هناك ازمه
بين السلطه القضائيه والسلطه التنفيذيه هي
الحكومه في سبب اقاله الوزير همم
اللافته ان قرار المحكمه العليا جاء رغم
قيام وزير العدل الاسرائيلي بعرض خطه
اضعاف القضاء عشيه المداولات في ملف درعي
مع دبر تهديدا للنظام القضائي الاسرائيلي
الذي احاكم نتنياهو في ثلاث قضايا فساد
يتجاوزت كل الحدود بالتدخل في قانون اساسي
اقر باغلبيه 63 شخصا عكس رغبه الاغلبيه
للاسف المحكمه العليا تعتقد بانها حاكم
خفي لاسرائيل
تخالف القانون وحكومه لا تلتزم بالقانون
هي حكومه غير قانونيه
الائتلاف سيسرع التشريعات المتعلقه
بالقضاء بهدف محاوله اعاده درع الى منصبه
ومن بينها تغليب قرارات الكنيست على
قرارات القضاء وتامين اغلبيه للسياسيين من
الاحتلال في لجنه تعيين القضاء والغاء
فقره المعقوليه القضائيه كالتي حسمت امر
درعي باعتبار انه غير معقول ان يبقى وزيرا
بعد ايداداته المتكرره بقضايا فساد الملك
المعركه بين التوليفه الحاكمه في اسرائيل
ونظام القضائيه شهدت نقله نوعيه بالغاء
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه توزير درعي
تصب الزيت على نار المواجهه الدائره في
البرلمان وفي الشارع الاسرائيلي ايضا زياد
حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه
تعلن تنحيها عن منصبها
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنت رئيسه وزراء
نيوزيلندا جستندا اردين تنحيها عن منصبها
بحلول السابع من فبراير المقبل في خطاب
امام اعضاء حزب العمال والذي تنتمي اليه
ايمانا بانه يمكنك ان تكون لطيفا ولكن
قويا متعاطفا ولكن حاسما متفائلا ولكن
مركزه يمكنك ان تكون قائدا كيف ما تريد
ولكن يجب عليك معرفته متى يحين وقت الرحيل
[موسيقى]
طبعا كما ذكرنا سابقا مشاهدينا بان
البرلمان الاوروبي يصوت اليوم على تصنيف
الحرس الثوري الايراني ووضعه في القائمه
السوداء
المنظمات الارهابيه وحول ذلك ينضم الينا
من بروكسيل مراسل العربيه نور الدين
الفريدي اهلا بكم نور الدين اذا مواقف عده
حول ايران ما ابرز هذه المواقف الصادره من
البرلمان الاوروبي حتى الان
صباح الخير فاطمه بعد ثلاث ساعات من الان
يصوت البرلمان الاوروبي على قرار
يتضمن بعد الفقرات غير المسبوقه حيث يدعو
البرلمان الدول العضاء اي الاتحاد الى
استهدافي القيادات العليا في ايران واولهم
المرشده اعلى علي خامنائي وكذلك الرئيس
ابراهيم رئيسي
والمدعي العام محمد جعفر منتظري
وعائلاتهم في قوائم العقوبات الاوروبيه
ذات الصله في انتهاكات حقوق الانسان
يدعو البرلمان الاوروبي في فقرات المشروع
القرار الذي سيعرض على التصويت بعد ساعات
الى ادراجي الحرس الثوري الايراني
والمؤسسات المتفرعه عنه والمرشات او فيلق
القدس في قوائم الارهاب الاوروبيه
القرار يدعو ايضا الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
دعم لجنه التقسي الحقائق الدوليه يدعو
ايران الى الافراج عن الرعايه والتوقف عن
استخدامي سياسه سياسه او دبلوماسيه
يعني هل قرارات البرلمان الاوروبي ملزمه
لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي
في مجال السياسه الخارجيه قرار البرلمان
الاوروبي ليس ملزم ملزما في مجال السياسه
الخارجيه قرار البرلمان الاوروبي ليس
ملزما انما هو راي راي استشاره يسرى اليه
من قبل الدبلوماسيه يعكس خاصه مزاج الراي
العام وعندما تجمع الكتل السياسيه مثل ما
تجمع في مشروع القرار المطروح اليوم مع
ذلك ان جوزيف بوريل سياخذ ذلك بعين
الاعتبار لا يمكنه ان يتجاهل وجود موقف
البرلمان لكن البرلمان له صلاحيات همم
تشريعيه وقويه جدا في مجال
الموازنه سواء كان موازنه الاتحاد
الاوروبي او موازنات التعاون الدولي بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي وتونس والجزائر وجنوب
افريقيا وفيتنام يمكن
وفلسطين مثلا يمكن الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
يعطل موازنات التعاون مع هذه الدوله او
تلك اذا راى
واستنتج في مراجعات الموازنه ان هناك نوع
من التلاعب وعدم التقيد بالقوانين
الاوروبيه وقوانين الشفافيه اذا ليس رايه
موقفه السياسي يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار ليس
منزلا للبرلماني صلاحيات في ما تتعلق في
خاصه على الميزانيه داخليا له رايه القوي
جدا في مجله البيئه والصحه الى غير ذلك
شكرا
على رفع سن التقاعد وارتفاع اسعار المواد
الاساسيه من وقود غاز كهرباء ومواد غذائيه
ومن المقرر الغاء معظم رحلات القطارات في
البلاد اليوم مع تاثر الرحلات الجويه ايضا
وتعطل مترو الانفاق بشكل كبير في باريس
الخميس الاسود دعت اليه ثمان نقابات
رئيسيه في فرنسا وسيكون بدايه لسلسله
اضرابات وتظاهرات تتخوف الاستخبارات
الفرنسيه من ان تمتد لعده ايام وتؤدي الى
شلل قطاعات معينه بالكامل بدعوه من احزاب
وقوى سياسيه ونقابات ولكن ايضا من خارجي
اي اطار حزبين ونقبي
من باريس معنا مراسل العربيه حسين قنيبر
اهلا بك معنا احسن اذا اضرابات هي ليست
الاولى في عهد
ولكن لماذا تتخوف الاستخبارات الفرنسيه من
هذه المظاهرات تحديدا
اهلا بك فاطمه في مذكره جديده للاستخبارات
صدرت قبل ساعات تضيف معلومات اخرى الى
المذكره السابقه التي كنتي تحدثت عنها في
مقدمه الخبر افيدا ان الاستخبارات تتوقع
ان ينزل الى الشارع خلال تظاهرات اليوم
عبر فرنسا ما يمكن ان يصل الى 750 الف
متظاهر من بينهم حوالي 80 الفا في باريس
وحدها تخشى الاستخبارات في مذكراتها التي
صدرت قبل ساعات من احتمال وجود ما بين 200
و400 متظاهر من المخربين الذين قد يعمدون
الى الهجوم على كل ما يرمز الى ما يصفونه
بهيمنه راس المال والاغنياء وقد يكون
بالاخلال بالنظام العام هؤلاء ينتمون كما
تقول مذكرات الاستخبارات الى مجموعات
يساريه متطرفه وهناك ايضا
6 متطرف من من تسميهم المذكره بمتطرفي
السترات الصفر الذين قد يحاولون ايضا
تخريب هذه التظاهره او بعضا من وجوهها
بحسب المذكره نفسها 10,000 عنصر امن
سينتشرون عبر فرنسا من بينهم ثلاثه الاف
1500 ينتشرون لمواكبه التظاهر الفارسيه
التي تنطلق عند الثانيه من بعض الظهر
بالتوقيت المحلي لمساحه الجمهوريه
الخميس هذا بالخميس الاسود والتخوف من ان
يكون خميسا اسود
نعم لذلك لهذه الاسباب التي تذكرينها ولكن
ايضا لان هذا النهار ستشمل اضراباته
والتحركات الشعبيه والنقابيه فيه عده
قطاعات من بينها القطاع الحكومي قطاع
الوظائف الحكوميه وايضا قطاع النقل
بلخصوصا انقطاع النقل التنقل بين المدن
الكبرى في فرنسا وبين الاحياء الرئيسيه
داخل المدينه الواحده ستشمل التحركات ايضا
الموانئ وكذلك المصافي النفطيه والمدارس
ومحطات الكهرباء يهدد بعض النقابيين من
المضربين بقطع الكهرباء رمزيا لتشعر
الحكومه بمدى الضغط عليها حركه النقل شبه
مشلوله حتى المصور الذي كان يفترض ان يكون
معي في الشارع لم يتمكن من الوصول الى
مكتب مصور العربيه كل ذلك احتجاجا كما
ذكرت على ارتفاع الاسعار وعلى موجه الغلاء
ولكن خصوصا على قرار الحكومه من خلال
مشروع القرار الذي
على البرلمون الشهر المقبل قرار الحكومه
برفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما حاليا الى 64
عاما بحلول العام 2030 الحكومه تراجعت
امام الضغط الشعب والنقابي كانت تريد رفع
سن التقاعد الى 65 عاما لكنها تراجعت
وتنوي رفعه الى 44 عاما طيب حسين يعني هل
هناك جبهه عماليه موحده وتدعو الى هذه
المظاهرات والى اين يمكن ان تتسع هذه
المظاهرات للجبهه العماليه
موجه الاحتجاجات التي ستتواصل فاطمه طوال
هذا الشهر تذكرنا بموجه احتجاجات كانت
حصلت قبل 28 عاما خلال عهد جاك شيراك في
ولايته الاولى في السنه الاولى من ولايته
الاولى وخصوصا في عهد يعني عندما كان الان
جوبير رئيسا للوزراء حصلت هذه التحركات
على نطاق واسع تحركات اليوم ستعاقبها
تحركات يوم السبت المقبل تحرك اليوم هو
النقابي بامتياز دعت اليه نقابات عماليه
رئيسيه على راسها الكونفدراليه العامه
للعمل
والكونفدراليه الفرنسيه
القوه العامله اما تحرك السبت المقبل فهو
بدعوه من اقصى اليسار تحديدا من حركه
فرنسا الاصليه وسيمضم ستنضم الى تحركات
السبت المقبل المنظمات الشبابيه في احزاب
الاشتراك والشيوعي والبيئه اذا التحرك
سيكون بدعوه من احزاب اليسار خصوصا حركه
فرنسا الاصليه اما تحرك اليوم فهو تحرك
دعه اليه النقابات العماليه الرئيسيه
وبالعوده الى سؤالك نعم هناك توحد للجبهه
العماليه من خلال اتفاق نادر حصل بين
النقابات العماليه الرئيسيه على توحيد
جهودها لانجاح لانجاح تحرك اليوم الذي هو
للتذكير قد يصل عدد المشاركين فيه على
الارض عبر التظاهرات الى
750,000 كما تقول مذكره الاستخبارات
الفرنسيه لكن مصادر نقابيه عماليه لم
تستبعد وصول هذا العدد الى مليون متظاهر
وهذا اكبر واوسع تحرك شعبي في فرنسا
تفضلي كنت اسالك عن الاستعدادات الامنيه
كيف رصدتها وكيف تجري يعني ذكرت بان مصور
العربيه لم يتمكن من الوصول الى المكتب هل
بسبب الاغلاقات الامنيه ام بسبب عدد
المحتجين في الشوارع
هو لم يتمكن من الوصول الى مكتب في الواقع
لان الشلل الذي يصيب قطاع النقل ادى الى
تعقيدات كبيره بالنسبه للذين يرغبون في
الوصول الى اعمالهم لكنني علمت انه وصل
الى المكتب قبل دقائق من الان او وسنكون
بعد قليل في الشارع لرصد ما يحصل في كل
الشوارع في معظم الشوارع الفارسيه التي
ستتجول فيها اشاره اخيره الى ان التحركات
ستشمل ليس فقط باريس ولكن ايضا المدن
الفرنسيه الكبرى من بينها مثلا مرسيليا
واليوم وليل وتولوز وايضا مدن منطقه في
تحركن من المرجح ان يتواصل على مدى
الاسابيع المقبله فاطمه
الامنيه حول الاحتجاجات حسين
هذه الاستعدادات الامنيه تتركز في المدن
الرئيسيه التي قد تشهد التوترات ولكن
خصوصا بالنسبه لباريس تتركز حول ساحات
ثلاث رئيسيه ساحه الجمهوريه لابلاس دولاب
بيبليك الذي ستنطلق منه التظاهر عند
الثانيه من بعد الظهر بالتوقيت المحلي
وايضا مساحه التي سيصل اليها المتظاهرون
في خطوه الاولى وساحه لناسيون ساحه الامه
التي يصل اليها المتظاهرون في نهايه
المطاف يعني في نهايه تحركهم عند هذه
الساحات تتركز الاستعدادات الامنيه وينتشر
الاف عناصر الامن في هذه الساحات الثلاث
وحولها ولكن ايضا في مناطق اخرى خصوصا عند
جده وفي محيطها ولكن خصوصا حول الساحات
الثلاث الكبرى الفارسيه التي ذكرتها شكرا
لك من باريس مراسل العربيه حسين جنيبر على
لهذه المعلومات
في انجلترا اضرابات من نوع اخر حيث اطلق
الممرضون هناك اضرابا جديدا يستمر يومين
لمواصله حركتهم الاحتجاجيه غير المسبوقه
من اجل تحسين اجور وظروف العمل في وقت
تواجه المملكه المتحده تضخما مرتفعا وكشف
استطلاع لمعهد يوغا يوغاف نشرت نتائجها
اليوم انا ثلث الممرضين والممرضات
والقابلات في القطاع العام قالوا انهم
كانوا سيختارون مهنه اخرى لو عاد بهم
الزمن للوراء من جانبه دعوى وزير الصحه
ستيف وركلي الى حوار بين مع النقابات
مبدئيا رغباته في التوصل الى اتفاق على حد
ادنى من الخدمات لضمني حمايه المرضى
باستمرار واكد الوزير ان اضراب الممرضين
يومين في ديسمبر الماضي ادى الى الغاء
ثلاثين الف يا جراحيه وموعد طبي
الى منطقه قصر بن غشير قرب مطار طرابلس
الدولي بعد وقوع اشتباكات بين مجموعات
مسلحه واكد مصدر امني لقناه العربيه اصابه
شخص واحد يتبع تشكيلا مسلحا بجروح طفيفه
[تصفيق]
الى تركيا حيث التقى رئيس جهاز المخابرات
هاكان في دان مع رئيس حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه عبد الحميد الدبيبه ورئيس المجلس
الاعلى للدوله خالد المشري في طرابلس
واشار المشري الى انه عقد ايضا اجتماعا
موسعا ضمه الى جانب الدبيبه وفيدان نائب
رئيس المجلس الرئاسي ومحافظ مصرف ليبيا
المركزي
في ليبيا تضرب الخلافات جميع الاطراف
السياسيه في مقتل
فعلى انقاذ اي اتفاق جديد يولد خلاف اخر
وسط تدخلات خارجيه هذه المره ترمي تركيا
بثقلها في خلافات الغرب الليبي وساطه
تركيه بين رئيس الحكومه المنتهيه ولايته
هو رئيس المجلس الاعلى بين عبد الحميد
البيبا وخالد المشري مصالحه تمت برعايه
خالصه من رئيس المخابرات التركيه الذي عقد
اجتماعيا المنفصلين احدهما برئيس حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه والاخر برئيس المجلس
ليختتمان بلقاء صلح بعد الخلافات الاخيره
للانتخابات
سيصرف المليارات ويقاتل عبد الحميد باي
بني منعها رئيس مجلس الدوله حدث بينه وبين
رئيس النواب تقارب اخر لكنه فشل بعد
تصريحات تعقيل صالح بان الاتفاق مع المشري
لا يتعدى ان يكون لفظيا تصريح قابله اخر
قطع ورقه الانعاش الاخيره بين شخصين لم
يتفق يوم اصلا في وقت تعود فيه المياه الى
مجالها بين الدبابه والمشري الاخير الذي
ادعم فتح بشار بقوه ثم توسع الجفاء ايضا
بينهما لاحقا
تحركات تركيه في الغرب الليبي تقابلها
تحركات امريكيه اخرى شرقا وغربا حيث زياره
مدير وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه الى ليبيا في محاوله للجمع بين
خليفه حفتر وقوتي العسكريه وعبد الحميد
زبيبه وقوته سياسيه وذلك بعد اخر لا يغيب
عن التدخل التركي لتهدئه قيادات الغرب
وعقد هدنه بينهما في ظل الانتخابات
التركيه المرتقبه مع محاوله انقر المستمره
لايجاد موت قدم لها في الشرق الليبي
وتامين مصالحها وسعيها للامساك بخيوط
التطورات السياسيه الليبيه
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
معكم بعد الفاصل الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب يضغطوا على موقع
احييكم من جديد حضر رئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب موقع فيسبوك على اعاده تفعيل
حسابه على المنصه الاجتماعيه بعد نحو
عامين من اغلاقه
بينما يستعدوا لاطلاق حمله حمله ترشحه
للبيت الابيض للمره الثانيه وكان فيسبوك
حضر حساب ترامب في اليوم التالي السادس من
يناير في عام 20 21 عندما حاول حشد من
مؤيديه وقفه عمليه تنصيب من خلال اقتحام
من الكابتل في واشنطن
يعاني الكثير من اللاجئين السوريين في
الاردن من قله المساعدات المقدمه وتراجع
حجم المساعدات خاصه في فصل الشتاء اضافه
لعدم قدره الاردن في الاستمرار بدعم
اللاجئين واصطى تراجعي حجم الالتزام
الدولي
لا تتغير ملامح المخيم بقدر ما تتغير
ملامح اهله من اللاجئين خاصه في فصل
الشتاء معاناه ليست جديده
وقله التمويل قصه الحاج محمد لا تختلف عن
غيرها من قصص اللاجئين ثمن اسطوانه الغاز
هو ما اثقل كاهله اكثر من وزنها الذي
يحمله على كتفه يواجه هو واحفاده برد
الشتاء وقله المساعدات في وقت ماتت فيه
عودته للبلاد مستحيله خوفا من معاناه اكبر
هناك
بالليل
ثلاث اربع مرات مغطيهم وخاصه بالليل
الحمد لله
العالم
احتياجات اللاجئين السوريين في الاردن
في السنوات الاخيره للاردن اكثر من 25%
اضافه لشرح المساعدات من المفوضيه وماذا
من تداعيات الازمه الاوكرانيه
الاول والثاني كان هناك
حماسه دوليه في الوقوف الى جانبنا
خلال سنوات الاخيره لم يصل حجم الالتزام
الدولي
بمساندته
لا اكثر من 25% اسطوانه الغاز واحده تعتمد
عليها عائله الحاج محمد في الطبخ ووسيله
للتدفئه ايضا ايام قليله قبل نفذ هذه الاس
انا والمواجهه مع فصل الشتاء في سباق مع
الزمن ينتظرون فيه شمس يوم جديد علها تحمل
املا طوته سنوات اللجوء من مخيم الزعتري
شمال العاصمه عمان سوها جميل العربيه
هذا عن وضع اللاجئين السوريين في الاردن
اما في لبنان فوضعهم منذ اكثر من اسبوعين
والطلاب السوريين خارج مقاعد الدراسه
فاضرابه اسد اساتذه التعليم الرسمي بسبب
عدم زياده رواتبهم دفعه بوزير التربيه الى
وقف تعليم السوريين حتى حل الاسماء
هو ليس بالوقت السعيد الذي يقضيه هؤلاء
الاطفال في لعب كره القدم بل هو محاوله
لتمرير وقت الدراسه التي منعوا عنها منذ
اسابيع بعد قرار وزير التربيه بوقف
التعليم السوريين بسبب اضراب الاساتذه
[موسيقى]
محمد المتفوق في دراسته يتحدث معنا عن
طموحه المستقبلي بعقل ساهم في نضره الالم
والحرمان الذي يعيشه كل اللاجئين السوريين
انه يسافر
اذا مدرسه
المدارس
الرسميه اوقفوا عن الدراسه بسبب قرار
وزاره التربيه مره جديده يدفعونها فواتير
غيرهم على حسابي مستقبلهم
تواصلنا مع الوزاره لسؤالي عن هذا القرار
الذي اعتبره الكثيرون عنصريا الا انها
رفضت التعليق لكن مدير مكتب الوزير كان
صرح سابقا بالقول لا يجوز ان لا يتعلم
ابناؤنا وان يتعلم اولاد غيرنا
نقدر
نحنا بنرفض انه نحن يستغلون ويجيبوا لنا
اموال مش هنسيب ازماتنا اليوم المعنيين
بلبنان هن بسبب الازمه رئيس الحكومي ووزير
المال وزير التربيه
والمعني الاول وزير التربيه لانه اليوم كل
القطاع التعليم واقف وبدل ما يطالب وزير
المال ورئيس الحكومي بالافراج عن الهبات
والقروض التي قدمت بيتجه
للعربيه الى ان اجتماعات متواصله تجري مع
المعانيين في الدوله اللبنانيه لحل هذه
الازمه رجعها ذلك خلال ايام
حتى فتحي ابواب المدارس يلقى الطلاب
السوريون واللبنانيون ايضا
رهائن الابتزاز الماليه الفاضح ناهد يوسف
العربيه بيروت